décidée non le coronavirus ne nous
laisse aucun répit
en plus de faire peur au monde entier ce
sont maintenant les marchés qui en
pâtissent le plus le 9 mars restera
comme un lundi noir les bourses des
différents pays s'effondre et on prédit
une croissance fortement ralenti un peu
partout tout le monde attend maintenant
les mesures des banques centrales pour
une fois de plus maintenir l'économie à
flot tant bien que mal la fed la réserve
fédérale des états unis a déjà baissé
ses taux d'un demi point et la banque
centrale européenne bas compliqué de
baisser des taux qui sont déjà au plus
bas
alors on fait ce tiroir cash on ne sait
pas encore ce qu'elle va faire mais on
imagine bien christine lagarde nous
sortir une politique
whatever it takes à la mario draghi oh
punaise christine lagarde
elle va l'intéresser celle là c'est si
rare mauvaise qualité lagarde
on est par des trolls le 9 mars ce sont
les cours du pétrole qui a enregistré
leur plus forte chute depuis 1991 et la
guerre du golfe après que l'opep et la
russie n'ait pas réussi à s'accorder sur
une baisse de la production pour limiter
les dégâts face à la baisse des
transports bref ce coronavirus déclenché
un vrai choc économique
attendez certains économistes parlent
déjà de crise financière ou de krach
boursier
coronavirus bientôt maîtres du monde